pour moi les réseaux sociaux en fait
c'est une bulle spéculative
et ce n'est pas le vrai monde alors
parce que c'est vrai que vous avez
traité d'abruti à partir du moment où il
y des choses qui plaisent pas ça me
dérange c'est ce que ça quand on vous
traite d'abrutis vous répondez quoi aux
gens en à droite pas être d'accord avec
moi ils pas partager mon point de vue
mais aussi beaucoup de gens qui m'ont
dit que j'avais raison aussi donc à
presser c'est normal c'est les débats
c'est mon est d'accord on n'est pas
d'accord madame n'est pas d'accord avec
moi guillaume n'est pas d'accord il ya
aussi par ailleurs beaucoup de gens qui
sont d'accord avec guillaume êtes
d'accord vous quand vous voyez ça sur
you re edit je sais que vous n'êtes pas
du tout d'accord avec elle sur sa
position sur wii non je comprends pas ce
que cette émission en fait c'est une des
rares émissions voir une des seules
émissions dans lesquelles on a des
débats animés avec des gens qui sont
pour la vaccination obligatoire des gens
qui sont contre et je pense que
géraldine au fil des mois toi tu es
devenu une sorte de symbole des gens qui
ne jurent que par la vaccination c'est
vrai et je ne jure pas que parler avec
les si et je pense que les gens en ont
ras-le-bol pour leur servent en fait
dans les médias certaines personnes ça
les gens ces gens c'est qu'ils agence
ces gens on parle de ces gens là qui ont
pris ce qu'ils vont dire abrutis kaunas
je pense pas que ça c'est isabelle
morini bosc
les gens en ont marre que les médias
racontent millions de personnes qui sont
allées faire vacciner oui il y en a
aussi fermé et y'en a marre oui je vais
dire un petit truc sur ça les chiffres
et je le dis
mec ne croyez pas qu'il ya 50 millions
de personnes qui sont là il en rire ou
mois effectifs regarde moi je vous dis
doivent d entre eux on à dire 40 % de
faux passe ne faut pas je peux vous en
parler parce que j'ai une de mes amies
donc natacha qui travaillent avec moi et
qui a vraiment enquêter et elle est
tombée sur des chiffres gouvernementaux
officiel disons qu'aujourd'hui et mes 36
% 36 pts et 900 de personnes qui ont
passé entre +20 parce que justement je
ressens rien non mais je vais vous dire
c'est qu'un meuble m c'est un souci je
veux dire c'est un gros souci parce que
il maxi donc le vaccin protège il compte
comme le vaccin protège imaginons que
ces personnes derrière attrape vraiment
le kobe ne sont pas vraiment vacciner
violents font défaut parce qu'ils sont
arrivés en real finalement ils ont avoué
qu'il n'était pas vraiment matinée oui
mais ça c'est marginal mais entre les
mêmes la cegos ceux qui ont l effet
placebo ceux qui sont à leur pic alors
on les pique à côté ce qui est bien
connu par le système les faux pas ce qui
se démultiplie qui n'a pas autour de
nous détailler ford et japonais d'en
face il ya peu défaut parce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut même rentré
partout avec des faux pas ce que je veux
dire c'est ce comédien et moi ce que je
voulais dire c'est qu'aujourd'hui j'ai
eu un copain juste avant de venir
l'émission qui est un journaliste qui
vit aux états unis c'est très
intéressant et et au canada il peut plus
vivre au canada parce que canada c'est
encore pire qu'en france il faut bien
l'avouer donc il est parti aux états
unis l'idée aux états unis où on ne
parle plus je sais pas si tu sais ça
sert il on ne parle plus que vides dans
les états du sud des états unis on ne
parle plus du coc vide il n'y a plus de
masques il n'y a pas de code qr je dis
bien et ça je suis sûr de mes services
pour aligner les terres du pardon des
forêts le sexage floride texas aux états
unis n'ont alors pour être aux états
unis pour y étudier et vivre pour y
vivre 62% des américains qui sont
vaccinées d'accord non mais pour le
reste sur place dans ces états là on vit
totalement normalement on ne parle plus
de corridas la télévision c'est terminé
maintenant cette plaisanterie elle doit
se terminer alors subir tous vaccinés
tous protégés c'est faux on le sert on
l'a vu tout l'été sur les autoroutes
mais c'est un truc de malade et on voit
très bien qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas le
cas pour revenir sur les critiques je
pense que tous les gens qui sont non
vaccinés et même ceux qui sont vaccinés
qui ont été vaccinés sous la contrainte
en ont marre que la plupart des médias
leur servent une sorte de pensée unique
à longueur de journée alors faire la
morale et je pense que ce genre de
propos ce fait les à gazaupouy je
comprends qu'il ne forme de déferlement
en revanche pas que tu prennes
personnellement parce que je pense que
font vos parents de ça et que tu
symbolise sa aux yeux de beaucoup mais
je suis très fier alors oui j non mais
c'est vrai que et en enlevant tout ce
qui est menaces et insultes
intimidations
mais par rapport aux fonds géraldine est
devenu une sorte de chantre de la bien
pensante gouvernementale qui est le tout
vaccin et c'est là donc je comprend
justement mais non mais je dirais que
ma phrase est signalé sur le fil à dire
ça y est la bienvenue en fait le pitch
ne rien dire chez moi tu as commencé en
disant une ineptie en fait on est
aujourd'hui dans le monde entier quel
est le pays aujourd'hui toyer vous
continuez machart gerald dénommé dis-moi
quel est le pays aujourd'hui qui ne fait
pas ce que fait le gouvernement au
niveau de la vaccination au départ les
états unis ne voulaient pas trump be
bizarrement il a mis 12 milliards sur la
table et c'est grâce à lui si on a eu la
vaccination aujourd'hui encore il dit
que lui il a eu trois doses maiden veut
la vaccination en italie vaccination
obligatoire en autriche vaccination l'y
attend en allemagne vaccination
obligatoire donc qu'elle est un brillant
de prix je ne reviens dire sans la dubai
vaccination
donc quel est le pays enfin je veux dire
moi je veux bien qu'on dise qu'on soit
anti macron c'est un truc non
du point de vue médical que j'ai le
sentiment pas nommément tu m'aimes on
s'aime pas pour faire plaisir à ma
crotoy là moi je suis j'ai réagi dans
ses messages il dépend qui m'appelle
zimbru ni anti main en la chose y entend
ça vous l'avez jamais confiance à la
halle ouest ces gens là viennent c'est
trop facile d'aller sur le terrain
politique est parlé pendant trois
minutes pour re complice parce que vous
devez lui dire parce que là c'est
compris ce que j'ai à lui dire c'est que
c'est normal qu'elles soient critiqués
parce qu'elle ne va que dans un sens et
elle seule a le droit de réponse est oui
non oui mais c'est non quand la critique
pascal stigma piste aucune partie des
gens mais qui est toujours à se faire
vacciner sting elle leur assène des
vérités du navire rouge et pour moi trop
d'hôtel le tient maintenant alors dans
ce cas là elle peut leur donner son avis
sur rien si mais on a droit de la
critiquer c'est ça la question
vous êtes obligé de vous vacciner madame
fait ce qu'elle veut elle est libre de
se vacciner